so you getting up several times of the
night having a urinate this video is for
you now this is mainly for men but if
you're female definitely applies to you
but just ignore the part when I talk
about the prostate the first thing that
you need to understand is the mechanism
behind this condition okay and it's so
easy to fix you should not have to get
up several times a night it's completely
unnecessary and if you do what I'm going
to show you you're gonna be able to
sleep the whole night and not have to
get up at all okay the mechanism what
happens is the bladder has smooth muscle
around it okay it has a muscle that
contracts and relaxes this particular
problem is a situation we are not able
to eliminate all of the urine the tone
or the muscle tone of the bladder is not
Foley contracting to eliminate all the
urine it contracts partially but there's
urine that's still in the bladder that
within one to two hours later it's gonna
activate a sensor that tell you to get
up and eliminate that small amount of
urine and it just keeps going on and on
and on so it's not really a problem with
the muscle it's the problem with the
nerve that connects to the muscle it's a
problem with the sympathetic nervous
system now real quick and this is
important the sympathetic nervous system
is normally considered a flight or fight
stress situation right and the
parasympathetic nervous system is all
about rest and digest so when you're
resting you're under the parasympathetic
control okay and it just so happens that
the smooth muscle that causes
contraction of the bladder is underneath
the parasympathetic now let me just
clarify what I'm why I'm bringing it up
because you would think that the
contraction that muscle would be under
the sympathetic yeah but it's not it's
under the parasympathetic because when
you urinate you can't actually be in a
stress State okay you're not it's gonna
be very hard to eliminate you have to be
fully relaxed and calm to eliminate that
urine from the bladder and when that
bladder fills up okay
and it has a normal tone that's under
the sympathetic nervous system so
regarding the bladder when you have too
much sympathetic okay we just don't we
don't get the contraction anymore we
can't fully contract and eliminate all
that urine so this problem really is a
sympathetic dominant problem and it's
caused by too much insulin insulin
triggers a sympathetic nervous system
okay and activates it and that's really
behind this
urination problem insulin enlarges the
prostate and many times people think
it's the enlargement of the prostate
that's causing all the problem but it's
not because when men have their prostate
removed many times they still have the
bladder problem it can be part of the
problem because the prostate is just
underneath the bladder and if it
enlarges it can obstruct this little
tube that the urine actually is coming
out to this tube right through here and
one of the medications they use to try
to help this problem or manage it it's
called an alpha blocker okay
alpha blockers target the sympathetic
nervous system now whether you have any
of these symptoms difficulty urinating
straining incomplete elimination of the
urine in the bladder or dribbling what
you need to do is lower insulin what
causes high insulin insulin resistance I
just have to explain this I'll try to
explain to some very simple terms
insulin is a hormone that lowers blood
sugars insulin goes into receptors in
the cell the body does not like to have
too much insulin it likes to have normal
insulin if there's too much insulin over
a period of time it will protect itself
by creating blockage within the receptor
it's called insulin resistance so
insulin resistance is a protective
mechanism against excessive amounts of
insulin here's the problem inside that
cell there's like a thermostat if it
detects low insulin it sends a signal to
the pancreas tell
the pancreas to make more insulin if you
have instant resistance you have between
five to seven times more insulin than a
normal person all that excess insulin is
going to create this problem okay loss
of tone in your bladder and enlargement
in the prostate so now the question is
what do we do about it what you do is
you lower insulin by cutting down the
carbohydrates that you're eating and the
sugars if you're doing candy through the
day if you're doing any type of popcorn
sugar you need to get that out of the
diet now I do have a link down below
that I highly recommend that you click
so you can learn how to do this it's
called healthy keto but what's even more
important is fasting in a minute fasting
why because fasting decreases the
sympathetic nervous system it fixes
sympathetic dominance it's a very very
powerful tool in fact I don't even think
the lowering of carbohydrates will be
enough to fix this problem but the
combination is going to be very powerful
but you of course you don't want to do
in a minute fasting without lowering
your carbs either you want to do both of
them so how do you do fasting very
simply you don't eat if you're not
hungry in the morning if you're not
hungry you don't eat normally people eat
in the morning they either breakfast
they think it's the most important meal
of the day that's false information when
you get up you try to go as long as
possible without eating if you're not
hungry
don't eat so most people can actually
when they start out have their first
meal let's say 11 o'clock in the morning
okay if your first meal and in the link
down below I'll tell you exactly what to
eat so just check that out okay you can
you can download that whole program the
check your first meal and then you go
all the way to maybe six or maybe seven
o'clock and have your second meal okay
you have two meals a day the key is
don't snack
you can't snack why because every time
you eat you increase insulin
so it's not just about the carbohydrates
it's also about the frequency of eating
so this is step one do this for maybe a
few days or a week okay and then you
graduate to stage two which is basically
gonna push your first meal full word as
long as you can
two maybe three thirty okay 3:30 or 4:00
that would be the ideal situation your
first meal 3:30 4:00 o'clock now when
you do this initially you're gonna feel
like oh my gosh I'm eating less times a
day am I gonna starve the whole thing
everyone goes through that it's not
going to be a problem you can have a big
meal it's not about calories if you have
that first meal and then the second meal
you you're probably not going to be
hungry but maybe in the first day or so
that you're doing this you'll have a
second meal maybe a few hours later so
you have these two meals and then you
don't eat but what's gonna happen when
you do this really big meal later in the
day like this you are not going to be
hungry from this point on okay now it'd
be great if you could just stop beating
from that point on and just do one meal
a day because not only will you fix this
bladder problem but you'll actually get
rid of the any type of extra fat in your
stomach that would be perfect but some
people I know this is hard to believe do
have a problem snacking at night they
have to eat something at night so for
those people I suggest you have this
first meal at 3:30 or 4:00 okay make it
big and then as your second meal do it
make it as a snack pistachios not
popcorn pistachios okay that could be
your second meal have some of those even
at 7 or 8 o'clock so you're doing
basically one and a half meals okay and
that would be your pattern of eating
that way you wouldn't feel like you
would have to give up something it would
make it a lot easier ideally and be
great if you didn't have to do that but
if you had to do that and then let's say
you do that at nine o'clock then you
fast all the way to the next day until
3:30 4:00 that's how you solve this
problem do it for two weeks okay
and watch the results comment below let
me know your progress and thanks for
watching so if you're enjoying this
content go ahead and share it with
someone that could really benefit from
it